firstly i just want to shout out ben
affleck for getting dunkin donuts two
days in a row
and still looking like a bowl of
shredded wheat
ginspiration secondly we have a lot to
talk about in regards to the current
batman situation
now i've been holding off on talking
about this because for 2021
i want to do more substantial videos
than just here's the headlines and
reading out someone else's article
i will be doing that in this video but
it'll be more in-depth i promise you
now the situation was obviously gonna
hit boiling point and i just wanted to
come in with a cool head
tell you what's been said and what i've
heard is really going on
if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who prefers to do the
breaking
of news in person but now this will have
to do for now
okay so over the christmas holidays
high-ranking warner brothers head walter
hamada had an interview with the new
york times
in which he discussed the studio's plans
for the future
and where things will be going warner
bros basically broke the internet by
announcing that their theatrical slate
was dropping on hbo max
and along with talking about this he
also detailed where things will be going
with the upcoming dc eu and other dc
properties
during the interview hamada said to make
all these storylines work
dc films will introduce movie audiences
to a comic concept known as the
multiverse
parallel worlds where different versions
of the same character exist
simultaneously coming up for instance
warner bros will have two different film
sagas involving batman
played by two different actors running
at the same time
not sure if he talks like that but let's
pretend he does now this caused a lot of
speculation with people jumping out who
it could be
and what it meant for the future ben
affleck's name was thrown in
keaton was dropped as well and there was
even some speculation that there would
actually be a batman beyond
since then though the journalist behind
the interview brooke barnes has
clarified that hamada was referring to
both robert pattinson
and michael keaton multiple outlets ran
this story
and built upon it by saying that ben
affleck would return for the snyder cut
and the flash
and then he would pass the torch to
keaton who would then take over the
mantle once more
from this position he would act as a
nick fury figure that oversaw the dceu
and this would allow him to become
somewhat of a mentor figure that could
usher
in heroes like batgirl and batman beyond
everyone went absolutely mental with
hardcore batfleck fans saying it was
fake news
and people who think batfleck is fully
out saying that
this just confirmed exactly what they
knew all along
however brooke barnes took some time
away and has came out and said the
following
being offline in brackets moving
apartments and returners see this
michael keaton craziness
i was referring to the one film that
keaton has been announced as being in
not a set of his own batman films your
bloody dingus
if i had info on him beyond the flash i
would have obviously put it in my
article
struth again not sure if he sounds like
that but pretend he does now obviously
the big question on everyone's lips is
still
what's in your apartment like and and
when when's your house party brook
the question following that is obviously
okay so
is ben affleck out and has he been
dunked in donuts
or you know words to that effect now
whilst we still don't have confirmation
on this
i'm gonna tell you what i've personally
been told by a reliable
source now this person wants to remain
anonymous and i don't want to get anyone
in trouble
so it's definitely not my uncle who
works at the warner brothers store in
the metro center newcastle
now from what i've been told ben affleck
is down for returning
and that he's up for continuing as the
character in one form or another
this is a sentiment that's shared by joe
manginello as well as jared leto
jay diggy recently even told variety
that he was down to return as the joker
at some point
and as we know from the leaked
information on the snyder cut he will be
reprising his role in an additional
scene
so they all want to do it however from
what i've been told
it's actually warner brothers that are
in the way and currently they want to
hold off and see how the sciatica does
before moving forward no one has signed
anything yet
and though there have been ideas put in
place the reason that actors like
affleck and so on are still regularly
taking other projects
is because they aren't holding off on
their career on the off chance that
something goes ahead
i found out about this last month and i
i've held off on reporting it for a
while now
as like i said i wanted to see how this
story developed
the funny thing is that i was actually
talking to brooklyn batman on twitter
about it yesterday
and as i told him i get so many rumors
thrown at me i tend to just wait to make
sure they're accurate
rather than simply trying to be the
first person out on the story
now dude hate this with a pinch of salt
and if you disagree yeah
that's cool as i said at brooklyn batman
it's not something i'd
put money on and to me it's solely a
rumor right now
however it does make sense that if the
snyder cut is successful and ben wants
to do it
that they would get him back from my own
personal point of view i'm still
50 50 on whether this is true or not i
just thought i'd tell you what i'd heard
i know the cultured nerd like cast and
war still back this story a lot longer
than i have
so full credit of them if it turns out
to be right
now i would obviously love to see ben
back and this kind of segues into
another of the big talking points which
is that hamada said the snyder cut would
end up going nowhere
before we get into that though i just
want to remind you that on the 30th of
january we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be with the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the story
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at heavy
spoilers and best of luck to everyone
who takes part
okay so back to hamada and when going
over the ramifications of the snyder cut
he said the following at least for now
mr snyder is not part of the new dc film
blueprint
with studio executives describing his
hbo max project as a storytelling
cul-de-sac
it's a street that leads nowhere you
bloody dingus
now this statement in my opinion is a
really stupid thing to say
even if it's true this is like an actor
coming out promoting a superhero movie
and then saying look it's not gonna go
anywhere there's not gonna be any
sequels after this
it's pointless getting invested in it
don't waste your time
hamada is supposed to be promoting the
project and to come out and say that
it's just a dead end seems super
short-sighted
a lot of casuals will probably now think
well there's no point in supporting this
thing
as even if it does make money it's not
gonna continue
so instead i'm just gonna continue
giving my money to disney
now as we know the studio has spent an
additional 70 million dollars on this
project
and it doesn't make any business sense
to me to invest all this cash
when you have plans of it going
absolutely nowhere zach's original
assembly cut was very close to
completion
and they could have just tweaked the
visual effects on that and put it out
without spending the budget of what the
original deadpool movie had
just to simply tweak things as mentioned
earlier there's also been some scenes
filmed on top of what was already part
of it
and to me at least it makes zero sense
to film these which set things up for
the future
just to mothball it a la bruce wayne
style now kevin smith talked about this
in depth with mark bernardin on his show
fat man beyond and he seemed as
bewildered as i
am let's play the clip i don't know why
i'm who i said that one i'm talking to
i'll i'll be the one editing in it
but play the clip to myself
um these two films told the the the
the times that that is a storytelling
cul-de-sac a street that leads nowhere
wait in other words dc films told the
new york times
that the hbo max event the snyder cut is
a storytelling cul-de-sac a street that
leads nowhere
in other words the snyder cut is not
part of the dc film's blueprint that's
been discussed here
um just that curiosity why would you
say that why would one feel the need to
put that out there
before this thing even happens because
what if it
you know [ __ ] takes the world by
storm in march
and people are like we want [ __ ] more
and [ __ ] well they're saying like
no there won't be more because i happen
to know that the ending
that he's got for the snyder cut
is very not
much not a cul-de-sac um
it takes it to a weird neighborhood but
it's not a cul-de-sac you can keep
[ __ ] going with the story based on
what i've heard
um from the front so
it's weird also given the fact that most
of the actors who are in the main line
dc
eu came from that you know since
you're not going to recast jason mower
you're not going to be
you know there's going to be more batman
um
who knows i still i still i'm i'm
uncertain about edgar miller
going forward even though warner
brothers seems you know locked and
loaded and ready to go with him
so there's always going to be a strain
of the snyder verse because these are
the actors who populated it
um but whether or not they're going to
give zach more license to make more
justice league movies
i think is the maybe not
but again like why
say that now like i would hedge my bets
and wait until march and the tale was
told
you know because that way if the
audience let the audience decide like if
the audience is like we want
[ __ ] more man then you you know you
you don't have to go back
on what you said like apparently it's
not a cul-de-sac let's keep going
okay so yeah he seems as lost as i am
now full spoilers for what we know about
the ending of the slider cut
so we don't want to know what the
cliffhanger is then i recommend that you
sky hook your way out of here before it
gets ruined
if you're still here shout out to
yourself and the movie will apparently
end with a five year time jump that will
pick up in the nightmare timeline
in it we will see batman joker and
deathstroke along with the flash and
mira
darkseid has completely destroyed the
planet and the movie ends with batman
saying he's coming
which is when we cut to black this is
why we have a night motivation of
deathstroke
and now that lito is going to be a road
weary version of the joker
so i just have no idea why they would
even bother filming this cliffhanger and
spending all this money
just to simply stop things there now
personally i think that warner bros are
still very bitter about the release of
the steiner cut
and it seems like they've just
deliberately cut off their nose to spite
their face when it comes to zack
they seem to just be wanting to release
this to show people up
and then hoping that the fan outcry goes
away but
if the movie is popular it just makes
absolutely no sense not to pursue this
now we did hear from scott snyder at
ccxp that he had been approached about
continuing this snyder verse in comics
but that due to his schedule he wasn't
able to commit to it
so there are things in place for the
universe to continue
but i actually think that it will go
beyond this if the schneiderker
is successful i can see them continuing
the nightmare version in either a live
action
hbo max show or at the very least an
animated series that lets them continue
the journey
we've seen how things like this worked
for the clone wars and rebels
and they ended up opening the door for
other things down the line
dc has a whole host of animated movies
as well
and it wouldn't be too much of an ask
for the actors to do voice-overs
over these sort of things should i ever
come to it however i do think that if
the snyder cup makes bank and gets a ton
of sign ups
that warner brothers would be stupid not
to continue it in some form or another
this is why hamada's comments make no
sense to me
and why i'm kind of torn over what i've
been told
as well as what the public's being fed
anyway that's the news
what i've heard and what i personally
think about the whole situation
i'm sure you guys have a lot to say too
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the 75 best easter eggs in cobra kai
season 3 which will be linked on screen
right now
we've we've made a whole thumbnail with
an arrow and a circle in it so
you know you better click it if if you
love that show as much as we do
anyway with that other way thanks for
sitting through the video yeah i've been
paul
i'll see you next time happy new year as
well peace
you